>> Emily: STARTING OFF WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT, ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS LEADING A CONGRESSIONAL
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER FIRSTHAND
TODAY, AND GET AN UPDATE ON THE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN COMING TO
THE BORDER.
HOWEVER ONE PERSON IS NOTABLY
ABSENT FROM THE TRIP,
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS.
TODAY MARKS HER 45TH STRAIGHT
DAY WITHOUT A NEWS CONFERENCE ON
THE BORDER SINCE TAKING ON A
LEADING ROLE TO DEALING WITH THE
CRISIS.
BUT EVEN WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT
M.I.A., THE CRISIS IS REAL.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS IN SOUTH
TEXAS ARRESTING 180 MIGRANTS AT
THREE STASHES NEAR THE BORDER.
CUSTOM PROTECTIONS AS THEY CAME
FROM MEXICO EL SALVADOR AND
GUATEMALA.
MEANWHILE WE ARE SEEING THE
NUMBER OF I.C.E. DEPORTATIONS
SHRINKING FROM MARCH TO APRIL
WHILE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES REPORTS THERE
WERE 22,000 UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
IN ITS COMPANY AS OF MAY 5TH.
THIS IS ON THE HEELS OF A COURSE
THEM SAYING IT’S BEING MANAGED,
BUT WE KNOW IT IS ELSEWHERE IN
THE SYSTEM, AND 18,000 MIGRANT
CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
THE CUSTODY AND PEOPLE OF ALL 50
STATES AND PUERTO RICO.
WHERE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Pete: SHE IS NOT GOING
THERE ANYTIME SOON, AND OF
COURSE HE GOES DOWN THERE NOW
THAT THEY HAVE EMPTIED OUT THE
BORDER FACILITY IS AND SPREAD
THEM ALL AROUND THE COUNTRY,
THIS IS NOT -- THE NUMBERS YOU
MENTIONED DON’T EVEN GO TO THE
ILLEGAL CROSSINGS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED THAT WE CAN’T ACCOUNT
FOR, BECAUSE ALL OF THE TIME HAS
BEEN SPENT FOCUSING ON A COMPANY
AND MINORS WHO ARE CROSSING AND
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
REIGNITING, BRINGING THE FAMILY
IS FROM THOSE COUNTRIES TO
REIGNITE THE MINORS, TALK ABOUT
INCENTIVE AND DEPORTATIONS ARE
AT RECORD LOWS, I.C.E. FEELS
LIKE THEIR HANDS ARE TIED.
IF I’M THE CARTEL THE ONLY
SIGNAL I AM SEEING IS BUSINESS
IS GOOD, NOT TO MENTION THE
REFUGEE BEING RAISED TO 125,000,
SO ALL THINGS CONSIDERED THE
ONLY MESSAGES THE BORDER IS
OPEN, KIDS HAVE THE GOLDEN
TICKET AND FAMILIES MIGHT BE
ABLE TO JOIN THEM AND THEY
FACILITATE SPREADING THOSE KIDS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY JUST SO THAT
TO THE DHS SECRETARY IGNORES THE
BORDER AND SHOWCASES HIS NEWLY
WIDE OPEN FACILITY, THE ONES
THAT THEY WOULD NOT LET US SEE
WHEN THEY WERE BACK.
>> Emily: AND KAYLEIGH IT
APPEARS THOSE IN THE WHITE HOUSE
ARE PARALYZED WHEN THEY TRY TO
DISCOVER THE ROOT CAUSES WHILE
IGNORING ALL THE PULL FACTORS
FROM THIS COUNTRY, THERE IS JUST
SILENCE IN THE WAKE.
WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF US THAT
ARE WAITING NOT ONLY FOR AN
ANSWER FOR ADDRESSING OR EVEN
JUST TALKING ABOUT THE TOPIC AND
BEING OPEN TO QUESTIONS, LET
ALONE ACTUALLY ACTING ON IT.
>> Kayleigh: I THINK IT IS
MORE THAN JUST SCIENCE, THERE
INSULT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THEY SHOW THAT IT IS NOT A
SERIOUS ENDEAVOR FOR THEM, AND
GOING WITH THE BORDER, SHE
LAUGHED, AND JEN PSAKI WAS ASKED
YESTERDAY WHEN BIDEN IS VISITING
THE BORDER, SHE SAID THAT
AMERICANS DON’T CARE ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, ESSENTIALLY HE IS
NOT GOING.
SHE WENT ON TO SAY THAT IT IS
TYPICAL, AND THERE IS A 20-YEAR
HIGH WITH ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
COMING TO THE BORDER.
AND GOING TO AN EMPTY FACILITY
WHICH IS THE ONLY REASON IT WAS
EMPTY IS BECAUSE THE KIDS HAVE
BEEN MOVED TO A FACILITY THAT WE
DISCUSSED YESTERDAY AND IT IS AN
ALL-TIME RECORD HIGH IN THE
UNITED STATES HISTORY THAT WE
HAVE 25,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN IN FEDERAL CUSTODY.
AND WHAT DO THEY DO, THEY
LAUGHED, THEY SAY THAT NUMBERS
ARE COMING DOWN AND IT’S TYPICAL
AND THEY DON’T VISIT OUR BORDER.
SO THIS IS NOT SERIOUS FOR THEM
AND IT IS DIFFICULT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE
MAKING A HUGE MISTAKE, BECAUSE
THIS HELPED PRESIDENT TRUMP GET
ELECTED THE FIRST TIME AND THE
BORDER WILL BE FRONT AND CENTER.
IN TWO YEARS AND FOUR YEARS.
>> Emily: RACHEL, IN THE WAKE
OF THE CRISIS, THE MAJORITY OF
THESE CHILDREN ARE PUT IN
EMERGENCY SHELTERS WHICH AS WE
KNOW BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
OVERFLOWING AND EVERYONE IS SO
OVERWHELMED, THEY HAVE FOREGONE
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
FINGERPRINTING OF STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS.
THEY ALSO DON’T REQUIRE
LICENSING THE SAME POLICY
CONFORMING AS THE OTHER SHELTERS
DO NOT TO MENTION THAT IT IS
MORE EXPENSIVE AT $775 PER DAY
PER CHILD, SO WHAT GETS LOST IN
ALL OF THAT IS THE CARE OF THE
CHILDREN.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND LOOK AT THOSE
IMAGES, SO MUCH FOR ALL OF THE
PANDEMIC PANIC, IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS PANDEMIC AND THERE IS
ANOTHER VARIANT IN BRAZIL, AND
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE SEEING FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WHO
WALKS DOWN THE BUSINESSES, THIS
COMES RIGHT BACK TO THE
CHILDREN.
THESE CHILDREN ARE BEING USED AS
PAWNS FOR POWER AND A VOTER
DRIVE BY THE DEMOCRAT PARTY AND
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
WHEN PEOPLE GO, WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING?
THAT IS WHY, WE NEED TO GET TO
WHY IT IS HAPPENING.
SHE IS NOT COMING BECAUSE SHE
KNOWS WHAT THE PLAN IS AND SHE
DOES NOT WANT TO HAVE HER
FINGERPRINTS ON IT.
JUST REMEMBER WHEN TED CRUZ WENT
TO CANCUN WHEN HE WAS SUPPOSED
TO -- AND THEY SAID HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE IN TEXAS DURING
THE EMERGENCY AND BY THE WAY, HE
WAS A FEDERAL LEGISLATOR WHO
COULD NOT DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT,
THIS IS KAMALA HARRIS’ JOB, AND
THE MEDIA IS GIVING HER SUCH A
FREE PASS AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SEEING IT, AT LEAST
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING OUR
CHANNEL, EVERYBODY ELSE WATCHING
OTHER CHANNELS ARE NOT SEEING
THE IMAGES THAT WE ARE SEEING.
THEY HAVE MOVED ON BEYOND THE
CRISIS A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO ON
THE OTHER CHANNELS, BUT THIS IS
HAPPENING IN THE CHILDREN ARE
THE VICTIMS, CHILD TRAFFICKING
REMAINS A MAJOR PROBLEM, AND
THEY HAVE THEIR HANDS AND HER
FINGERPRINTS ON ALL OF THIS
DISTRESS AND ALL OF THE THINGS